Hi, Mystery Recapped here. Today I am
going to explain a Russian comedy film
called “The Pregnant”. Watch out and take care!
Sergey is a news reporter living somewhere in
Russia. He and his wife Diana have been trying
to have a child for the past two years but haven’t
been successful. At the beginning of the movie,
Sergey is with a therapist telling her about
his problems. He says that he wants a baby so
much that he has begun to dream about pacifiers
and strollers. The therapist asks him if he has
done the one thing that is necessary to get his
wife pregnant. Sergey proudly claims that they
have intercourse every night but his wife never
seems to get pregnant. They tried to change the
setting and have intercourse in cars but to
no avail. Sergei even wrote his wish down
on paper and ate it one time, but that didn't
work either. The therapist tells him that his
thoughts will become reality very soon, so he
should be careful. Sergei doesn’t understand
what she means but he doesn’t question her.
On his way to work, he calls his friend and lawyer
Zhora. Zhora has consecutively lost eight of
his previous cases and is struggling because of
financial difficulties. He has two daughters and
is trying for a son again. After talking to him,
Sergei gets to the set and presents a show
with his co-host. Somewhere else, Diana is
at an art exhibition where all the pictures
she has taken recently are being displayed.
Sergei is late as usual. When called, he
claims that he is already inside the car
and will be there in only five minutes. But after
the call, his car is towed away for being parked
in a restricted zone. Knowing that his wife will
find out about the lie, he ditches the exhibition
and instead goes to a bar with Zhora. As
they talk about children, Zhora mentions
that his wife is one month pregnant. They are
hopeful that it will be a boy this time because
Zhora wore felt boots while making love.
Their family has a superstitious belief that
every time a man makes love in those
shoes, the woman gives birth to a boy;
that is how Zhora, his father, and his grandfather
were born. The next day is Valentine's day. Sergei
and Diana go to the place they first met five
years ago. They promise to come to the place
with their children someday. Before returning
home, Sergei goes to buy felt boots. At night,
after having intercourse, he takes the shoes off
and hugs them, hoping to soon be blessed with
a child. When he cannot fall asleep, he walks up
to the window and prays. Seconds later, he sees a
falling star. Ten days after the incident, Sergei
is in the studio, presenting a program about a
chicken named Sonya. Sonya is a miracle animal and
the rebirth of Paul the Octopus. She can predict
the winners of football matches by laying eggs.
The number of eggs she lays is considered the
number of goals the winning team will score.
While reporting the news, Sergei suddenly pukes.
He apologizes and gets back to work, unaware
of the real reason for his morning sickness.
Later, he is at the grocery store buying
things for dinner when the pickle shelf catches
his attention. He has never liked sour
things in his life but for some reason,
he craves pickles more than anything that day. On
the phone, Zhora jokes about him being pregnant
but Sergei remembers his wish and thinks it might
be a possibility. That night, he finds Diana’s
pregnancy kit in the cupboard and decides to test
his theory. At first, he sees the two red lines on
the kit and thinks it means he isn’t pregnant.
But after reading the instructions, he figures
out that two lines mean he might have a baby
inside of him. He takes the test a few more times
but the results come back positive every single
time. The idea is so absurd to him that at one
point he starts laughing at the positive test.
The next morning, he has pickles for breakfast.
Diana notices his weird behavior and inquires what
is wrong. When Sergei tells her they are about to
have a baby, she thinks he cheated on her. But on
finding out that he is the one who is pregnant,
she gets even more upset, thinking that he has
gone insane. Sergei wants her to be happy about
being a father, but Diana needs some time
to take it all in. That evening, Sergei’s
parents and Zhora’s family come to their house for
dinner. Sergei takes the opportunity to officially
announce his pregnancy. The family is left
speechless at the announcement. They calmly try to
explain that him bearing a child is impossible.
Sergei storms out without saying anything
leaving everyone else in awkward silence.
His father blames his mother for doing pregnancy
yoga which he thinks messed with Sergei’s autonomy
and made him a woman from the inside. The next
morning, Sergei reads a book on pregnancy
and identifies his symptoms. He keeps the
negativity aside and starts to prepare for the
child’s arrival. On calculating the due date,
he is happy to find his child will be a Leo.
Starting that day, Sergei stops smoking and
eats pickles with every meal. He even listens
to children’s bedtime stories so the baby could
hear them too. With time, Diana comes to terms
with the pregnancy and supports him to her best.
Four months into the pregnancy, Sergei now
has a protruded belly. He goes to pregnancy
classes every day but pretends to be there to
better understand his wife. The mothers do not
question his belly and think that he is just
trying to get the authentic experience.
While all his close ones know about the pregnancy,
he has chosen to hide it from the rest of the
world. In the fifth month, Sergei and Diana go
to a gynecologist for the first time. However,
as soon as the doctor sees that the husband is
the one who is pregnant, he refuses to treat him.
In a similar way, the couple visits many doctors
but none of them accept him as a patient.
Then, one day they come across Dr. Tikhonov
who has been in the business for two months
but hasn’t gotten a single patient. Because
he is desperate, he agrees to treat Sergei.
The doctor asks him to get on a delivery bed but
a stupid Sergei cannot figure out what goes on the
leg holder. Because of his unique condition,
he has to be on all fours for the checkup.
The following day at work, Sergei finds out that
Zhora has allowed the show to broadcast about his
pregnancy. As the word gets around, everyone
is intrigued by the man who got pregnant.
It becomes an international sensation, much to
Sergei’s annoyance because he wanted to keep
it a secret. People in the streets and the bus
now recognize him as the man who was knocked up.
They treat him like an outcast which
doesn’t help Sergei’s mental health.
He confronts Zhora about selling him out for
money but the man shows no regret. Instead,
he claims that he has more ideas that will
make both of them millionaires. At first,
Sergei curses him out, claiming that he won’t
sell his pregnancy. But when he calms down, the
money doesn’t sound so bad to him. Starting that
day, he goes to several TV programs and shows as
the pregnant guy. He is also made the sponsor of
several maternity products. His popularity grows
immensely in only a few weeks. He is surrounded by
paparazzi everywhere he goes and even his family
members are interviewed by many reporters.
One day, he is at a restaurant when a gay couple
approaches him. They too want to know the way
a man can have a child. Sergei has no clue how
he got pregnant but he still advises them to
wear a pair of felt boots during intercourse
and do it in a green room. In the next
gynecologist appointment, the couple finds out
that they are having a boy. Outside, the reporters
surround Sergei again. He gets so caught up in
their questions that he doesn’t notice Diana
being left behind. Ever since he got famous,
he hasn’t been the loving husband that he used to
be. Following that, Sergei gets a show of his own
where he provides maternity advice to women.
Zhora makes a lot of money profiting from the
show. However, the more Sergei works, the more
he starts ignoring his wife and her needs.
For one of the episodes, Sergei brings his family
to a restaurant and asks them all to talk about
his pregnancy. Diana lashes out at the cameraman
and storms off, having had enough of the show.
After the incident, all of his family members
leave, and Sergei is left alone for the first
time. He realizes that he has let fame get to
his head but before he can fix his problems,
a group of religious protesters protests against
him. When Sergei starts getting a lot of hate,
an opposing broadcasting company sues
his show for fraud. They claim that his
pregnancy is just a publicity stunt organized
to make money. In the first hearing, Zhora can
barely put his case forward while the prosecutor
impresses everyone with her thorough research.
She shows the judge a file of Sergei's personal
bank account that has all the information about
the profits he has made from his pregnancy.
At home, Diana asks him to stop all the games
and live a normal life as they did before the
pregnancy but an agitated Sergei yells at her.
In the second hearing, Zhora brings Sergei in
front of the judge and shows his belly to everyone
present there. He even presents the ultrasound
results as evidence. To prove him wrong,
the prosecutor brings Sergei’s gynecologist
to court. According to her, since Sergei is
the doctor’s first patient, the doctor is not
experienced enough for such a complicated case.
Instead, she shows the judge a research from
much more experienced doctors who claim that
male pregnancy is impossible. By the end of the
hearing, Sergei seems to be losing the case.
One day after an interview, Sergei returns
home to see that Diana has left him. He panics
and realizes how badly he had been treating
her recently. The only way for him to gain
her trust back is by giving up the show.
Hence, in the next and the last hearing,
he doesn’t go to court. Zhora panics but
still gives a heartfelt speech about Sergei
being a great mother. Everyone in the court
claps for his excellent words but just then,
the judge receives a video sent by Sergei.
Zhora doesn’t think much of it and allows it
to play. To his utter surprise, in the video,
Sergei claims that he lied about the pregnancy
and is sorry to everyone he hurt in the process.
He also asks for forgiveness from Diana who has
always supported him. After hearing him confess,
the judge declares him guilty and charges him a
fine of one million rubles. Everyone who believed
in him, including all his fans, is disappointed.
Sergei meets Diana at their favorite place
and apologizes for being a bad husband
and using his pregnancy as a tool. The two
kiss when suddenly, Sergei’s water breaks.
He is rushed to the hospital where the doctors
successfully perform a c-section on him.
After the birth, Sergei tells his family that
he has chosen love over money. They are proud
of him for being brave. Diana brings their
baby and hands him to Sergei for the first
time. Three years after the birth, Diana is in one
of her exhibitions that showcase the pictures she
took of Sergei during his pregnancy. Their son
has grown taller and is playing with Zhora’s
daughters. A few months later, Diana prays to have
a set of twins. Her wish comes true, making her
and Sergei pregnant at the same time.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on the notification, and leave a like to
help the channel out. Thank You for watching.